قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
رفعت من مستوى الدعم العسكري المقدم
لاوكرانيا في شكل انظمه الدفاع الجوي
وذخيره ودبابات بالاضافه الى مهمات
التدريب العسكري وان الحاجه لانجاز المزيد
لا تزال ملحه لدعمك
تنسيقنا يحدث فرقا حقيقيا في الوقت الفعلي
تعمل الولايات المتحده المانيا وهولندا
معا لتزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه الدفاع الجوي
كما تعمل فرنسا وايطاليا على توفير نظام
دفاع جوي وتعمل مجموعه من الدول لتوفير
دبابات قتاليه من طراز لاوكرانيا تقدم
الولايات المتحده وجمهوريه التشيك وهولندا
العربات المدرعه المملكه المتحده قدمت
عددا من دبابات من طراز تشالنجر وعملت مع
العديد من البلدان لتوفير المزيد من
الذخيره لاوكرانيا نعمل معا على تدريب
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه من خلال
مبادرات التدريب الثنائيه
والمتعدده الاطراف